In March 2020, as the pandemic lockdown went into effect,...
...one of the world's largest independent music stores...
...found itself closing down earlier than expected.
We had a lease and our lease was coming to a close.
We were in a pretty unsustainable situation financially on the other spot.
So, we had been looking for a place...
...where we can take the show on the road and recreate the magic.
Amoeba Music planned to leave its Sunset Boulevard address...
...to move to a brand new location in the neighborhood.
While the new Amoeba doesn't have an upstairs section,...
...it does have everything long-time fans expect.
We're still carrying everything that we had carried before,...
...so we're more than just a record store with music and movies and then you get into posters,...
...t-shirts, games, toys, lunchboxes, prayer candles there, you name it.
And we'll be enforcing masks and social distancing...
...and doing everything that we need to do...
...to make sure that it's a safe spot for our customers and our staff.
Hopefully, it's again a very familiar experience for people.
I mean, it still feels connected to this great new space as it did with the old one.